I don't know where Rishi sunak is um he  wasn't even in the country yesterday  this is unfolding in front of his eyes  he's the leader he's the core decision  maker he needs to get round the table  and so I say to him today because I've  heard that they're saying we can't get  Diaries together Etc all the general  secretaries are willing to come and see  him to negotiate and if he can't find a  date I'll give him a date the 25th of  December he won't have any meetings on  that day we are quite prepared to come  and talk to him on the 25th of December  if that's the only diary date that he's  got to make sure that we can bring  resolution to this dispute